every hour images are coming in this is
one of russian attack helicopters only
about 50 miles away from the ukrainian
border so let's put it onto the bigger
map
if we think about numbers the numbers
always matter in these cases and the
numbers are not very good for ukraine
ukrainians have got about 125 000 troops
that they could call on reasonably well
trained the russians have brought in at
least 160 000 troops the americans even
say they may have 190 000 troops
ukrainians have got about 580 main
battle tanks that they can use the
russians have got 1300 battle tanks that
they can use
the ukrainians may be hoping that they
can rely on their bairachter missiles
their director drones these drones are
bought from uh uh from turkey
and they're very good uh anti-tank
drones they worked extremely well for
the azerbaijan government in its battle
with armenia a couple of years ago but
just going back to the big map again
we talk about what happens it happens on
the ground it's really dominated by what
happens in the air and at sea i mean in
the air
the ukrainians essentially lost most of
their air force in 2014 they've
reconstructed about 120 combat aircraft
but the russians have already put in
theater about double that number 220 to
230 combat aircraft and at sea even more
importantly the ukrainians essentially
lost the whole of their fleet in 2014
they've got more or less one frigate and
just a coastal force known as the
mosquito navy it's quite good but it's
very small
the russians have brought 30 major
battleships into
the black sea those ships include seven
missile carrying ships they include
three kilo class submarines they've been
trying to draw our attention to that in
all the stuff that they've released in
the last couple of hours
and it includes six landing assault
ships they three of those came through
the bosphorus only a few days ago we
don't know what's on those ships but
normally they carry uh tanks armored
vehicles and troops
the fact is that by land sea and air
president putin has a vice around
ukraine and he can snap it shut if and
when he decides to
back to you anna